m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el lugar donde todo el peso
el lugar donde todo empezó san josé de
cúcuta y área metropolitana vamos a
poder indicar algunos elementos que
fueron claves para esta región la
primera parte
tenemos un símbolo histórico de nuestra
región allí se conforma la gran colombia
en este espacio junto con situaciones
políticas también se presentan
situaciones que generaron un proceso
industrial donde fue prácticamente el
inicio de una gran revolución aquí uno
de los símbolos principales de ese
escenario tecnológico con los cuales
nuestro nuestra región empieza a ser
reconocido a nivel nacional e incluso a
nivel internacional
el lugar donde todo empezó tiene un
grato recuerdo la primera exportación de
café hacia el país cercano venezuela el
año 1900 refleja la primera exportación
con origen desde norte de santander con
granos y cultivos que venían combinados
de municipios cercanos como salazar de
las palmas gramalote y otros cercanos a
esta región
sin embargo en la actualidad todos los
indicadores muestran que esa realidad ha
venido perdiendo protagonismo dos
elementos claves uno la representación
en términos de competitividad el foro
económico mundial
habla de que nuestra ciudad a pesar de
que en el 2017 ocupa el puesto 6 de 33
ciudades analizadas en colombia y en el
2012 que fue la última medición y
estamos en el puesto 20 aún hay varios
elementos que estamos pendientes por
desarrollar
colombia ocupa en la actualidad para el
año 2017 el puesto 59 de 150 y 190
países en el mundo lo que implica un
reto importante para empezar a trabajar
en las oportunidades que existen
este escenario nos identifica en cuatro
grandes etapas las yemas las llamamos
las revoluciones la revolución 1.0 en
esta revolución el carbón y el
ferrocarril fueron los elementos claves
del desarrollo de una sociedad que
empieza a industrializarse en el
escenario de la revolución 2.0 la
energía eléctrica el petróleo y las
economías de escala empiezan a ser
protagonistas en el desarrollo de las
sociedades
en los años sesentas y en los años 70 la
revolución 3.0 nos obliga a automatizar
los procesos para hacer mucho más
eficientes los productos y aquí entra la
era de las tecnologías de la información
y la comunicación y en la actualidad
estamos entrando a la industria 4.0
basada principalmente en la conexión y
en el internet de las cosas
pero cúcuta fue la piedra en colombia la
experiencia de la industria 1.0 aquí
podemos observar uno de los elementos
claves de la industrialización por el
cual colombia empezó ese proceso a
finales del siglo 19 y principios del
siglo 20 el ferrocarril de cúcuta pero
al lado tenemos ese mismo ferrocarril
pero hoy en día como parte de un punto
histórico y turístico y cerca al
terminal de transportes de la ciudad sin
embargo nuestra ciudad fue llamada la
ciudad cosmopolita la integración y la
movilidad social eran una dinámica que
hacía que esta ciudad fuera el referente
en muchos de los negocios a nivel
nacional e internacional
sin embargo roger van horn nos invita a
reflexionar lo siguiente no es posible
resolver los problemas de hoy con las
soluciones de ayer lo que acabamos de
ver es lo que fuimos y ahora vamos a
tratar de empezar a construir una nueva
historia
qué tal si empezamos con la aplicación
de la industria 4.0 esta imagen refleja
en un salón de clases de cuarto primaria
en un colegio en la ciudad de madrid
esto es tomado del periódico del país de
españa una clase de ciencias naturales
donde el profesor está tratando de
explicar cómo funcionan los ecosistemas
y subsaharianos y todos los elementos
que allí los rodean ahora imaginemos por
un momento un salón de clase en puerto
santander en el zulia en gramalote en
durán ya donde estos chicos a esa edad
tengan la posibilidad de acceder a este
tipo de elementos tecnológicos que
podrían hacer que su desarrollo
profesional y de calidad empezará a
funcionar de una manera mucho más
acelerada tal vez tendríamos allí la
cura contra el cáncer tal vez tendríamos
allí algún muchacho que nos ayudará a
convertir el agua salada en agua dulce y
muchos de los retos que
la humanidad planteados para los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
esta aplicación de la industria 4.0 no
es lejana ya hay sectores como por
ejemplo el sistema modas y el comercio
de bienes y servicios que utilizan
elementos propios de la industria uno de
los claves por ejemplo tiene que ver con
el drone y por qué no imaginar el
próximo año un modelo de negocios start
apps donde el pastel de garbanzo y por
ejemplo la yaca fuera entregado con un
dron interesante verdad
de hecho pedíamos el pastel de garbanzo
más que por el pastel por ver el drone
llegar y eso podría ser una posibilidad
real en los próximos años sectores como
la arcilla y la industria están
utilizando procesos de robotización eso
ya se está viendo no solamente los
países desarrollados siendo en los
países emergentes sectores como el
turismo que es una de las apuestas
productivas de la región el diseño
gráfico aplican la simulación y la
simulación es uno de los elementos de la
industria 4.0
a mezclar la realidad física con la
realidad virtual y en sectores como la
mecánica automotriz la palma de aceite y
otros agroindustriales se está
utilizando la realidad aumentada para
ser cada vez más eficientes en los
procesos productivos
como lo logramos
tres elementos fundamentales el primero
romper aspectos culturales que traemos
en torno a la tecnología y entorno a los
escenarios de ranking y de talla mundial
este aspecto cultural está relacionado
principalmente con una frase
bíblica que tiene que ver con el si
podemos y la hago referencia a esta
frase porque en los deportes lo hemos
logrado y en otros escenario lo hemos
logrado aquí nos hace falta incluirlo en
los procesos productivos y de
emprendimiento el segundo elemento clave
es la confianza la confianza es el
principal fundamento de toda relación
económica si no hay confianza entre los
seres humanos no se pueden desarrollar
lazos no se pueden desarrollar redes y
no se pueden hacer negocios que puedan
prosperar en el tiempo y por supuesto el
tercer elemento el trabajo en equipo ese
trabajo en equipo basado en rompimientos
y paradigmas culturales en afianzamiento
de la confianza y en escenarios donde
tengamos la posibilidad de generar
valores agregados compartidos hoy en día
es una realidad en el mundo a eso le
llaman la economía colaborativa
escenarios integradores donde la oferta
y la demanda rompen con los actuales
esquemas de lo que son los principios
fundamentales de la economía
por eso podríamos hablar que nuestras
pequeñas y medianas empresas pueden
estar interconectadas y desarrollar
procesos de economía colaborativa que
nos permitiría ir más allá de la
frontera y esa frontera tiene que ver
mucho con aspectos propios que nosotros
podríamos implementar porque mientras
que exista un sueño por más dificultades
que se atraviesen todo será posible si
iniciamos con la acción y la acción
inicia hoy con creer que podemos y somos
capaces
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]